welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig and
guess who's here he's me Mitchell Davis
oh you sent some meek and they come I
want to protect you
I'm just doing my version of my voice I
did in cats yeah guys we're going back
to basics we're doing what we do pretty
okay which is rent yes ranch ranch ranch
yeah you say like we're wrestlers you
know what I'm saying yeah today we're
coming at you great at you you are gonna
get then fury aided with it by minute 30
but we're gonna keep going it's a really
fun episode we touched on so many of the
topics that you guys submitted and we
learned a lot about each other as always
you know lots of sauces involved yeah
and so just to bear with it the entire
thing isn't about cats but it's gonna
seem like from the beginning a lot of it
is about cats it's just it's so nervous
like that yeah I want to think about it
it gives me hives okay enjoy this
episode of not too deep what stomach
hurts just think it serious it's not
okay to deep turn your great idea into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work or selling products of any kind
with beautiful templates and the ability
to customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you do get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com such Grace for a
free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain
[Music]
rock and roll Mitchell Davis was back in
the building kicking it off check in
this phone episode 500 well we finally
made it we did it we finally made it
I brought my son you bright is it
gendered no what are you talk about it's
a bee yeah it's a bee it's just an
insect it's a bee with like over plucked
eyebrows that's the most curious thing
to me about this bumble baby is that
there's hardly any like defined facial
features but they drew on two pencil
thin eyebrows a moment yes they did and
also those those those bottom teeth are
thick I think you can tell that this is
a jersey bee I got this at a thrift
store in New Jersey it's a baby with
four teeth that eats full meals you open
that beer with my teeth for you for beer
can openers for teeth
Mitchell thank you for being here I love
being here I'm here all the time
I'm so excited can we say that you're
moving I am moving yeah that's I mean
that's yeah yeah so Mitchell is moving
back to Ohio yeah yeah I've been here
for like four and a half years it's
crazy and I love putting caps on things
around five and yeah I just my family
was like so what's next what are you
doing next after a new format all this
and I was just like I don't know I kind
of just kind of just want to see what's
next and they were just they were that's
when my family like slyly was like you
know if you came back you could save a
little bit and travel and I was like
that sounds fun yeah a lot of fun I
think that's a great idea
I mean LA is fine but then it just wears
you down it breaks you down and then
you're like what am i I'm just floating
around spending money that I don't have
right now well I also realized that
everything I do in LA is so far away
from my apartment already I'm just gonna
fly in and sleep on somebody's couch and
do it and then just go home and save you
you hear that I'm gonna be on Grace's
couch my couch and goose will be in
another room goose will be my blanket
Danko but Mitchell texted me the other
day and he said since we're doing like
the last episode before I move out to
Ohio not the last episode indefinitely
why don't we do like old school rants I
just felt like it was right it feels
like the right time I've been too
positive for too long lately and that's
something that also I gotta bring up
it's like on social it's like you're
going through a relationship I get that
you're so good it's [ __ ] disgusting
every time I like something I'm just
like oh god grace is so happy every time
I posted I'm a girl god I guess I'm like
satisfied with life right now and I just
I this is my third phone I through two
phones right out the window like the
mask I was just like yeah it's honestly
I'm on the fourth floor it's not okay
not good gravity works okay I got some
Twitter rant topics we got a lot of them
and then I went on the gram and got a
couple more out sourcing from different
social media platforms just to see what
the differences were that's how you
build a business you outsource a little
bit there you go you know you work with
collab with people yeah you bring it all
together
bring it all together and then you know
what what you make a business make a
business that's how business works you
guys don't need to go to business school
you just graduated you just got it first
one the cats movie trailer this is a hot
pile of garbage okay no I understand
first of all lots of people's time
energy and talents go into making movies
yes I would all respect for how much
time and energy and money it costs to
make this movie this is a [ __ ] crazy
you only said all that because of your
like but there's crazy uh there's
something about it that just feels too
furry for me horrifying like seeing all
the images of James Corden oh no
and like some of the cats wearing shoes
and stuff uh what are we thinking I know
we thinking like who was like you know
one I've got an idea
kept me you know the Catwoman movie from
like seven years ago that did horrible
with Halle Berry when we just covered
her in spandex so it would be sexy well
what if we did that again except we made
them look like real [ __ ] cats yeah
and gave them human faces oh it's it's
it's like they took the technology from
Teletubbies with the baby in the Sun
yeah and then they used it to put faces
on to cats it looks like a weird you
know the younger filters and like the
gender swapping its to face up its like
the face app for cat filters but it got
stuck like halfway in between its other
half human half cats and it just makes
my whole body ache hide the fact that
you brought it up it's getting me gas
I'm getting gassy it's just something
about it just makes me feel so
uncomfortable the fact that their faces
look so real some of the cats look like
cats way more than other cats yes and
some of the cats are totally naked did
not need to rep was a rebel who puts her
hand in a in a mousetrap that's too
small but she's but she's a large cat
and they're at a dinner table side side
the Swift is there and she's pouring
catnip oh that's funny no it's not it's
just crap this last like run-through was
like beautiful I know well okay first of
all they're starting with cats which in
and of itself is a production that makes
no [ __ ] sense in the entire universe
yeah I don't even know what universe it
takes place in because like one cat goes
to space at the end
kimmy schmitt makes a joke about it
where he just walks up on stage and
starts singing go goes and then in the
background like in the back the
backstage area he goes you're part of
cats no he goes that is actually the
secret of cats is you just walk on stage
and the same and you become one of the
cats and I was like that seems right
because I've tried to watch a few clips
on YouTube and it's just like yeah what
the [ __ ] are these cats doing I have no
idea I have no idea the trailer also
felt like everyone's opinion about
something got a yes anyone that like
what if we do this like yes we'll do
that what if we do this yes I'll do that
what if James Corden's and
yes get him this is gremlins too like
this is gonna be up there like our kids
kids kids are gonna be like hey you guys
want to get [ __ ] up and watch cash
just [ __ ] scare yourself you remember
that you know that part where she
Springs that it's and we haven't even
seen it yet that's what's not and you
know what I'm gonna see that's like
that's the thing too is it's like I know
I'm gonna sit through this thing and I'm
gonna digest it and I'm gonna take it
and it's gonna be a part of me forever
and I'm gonna be more mad after I see it
but I'm gonna have had put myself into
that situation I'll be surprised if my
real cat at home throws up a few times
for it should be called humans that look
like cats
humans pretending to be cats the science
experiment that went weird yeah it's
like the Hermione Granger's the little
potion she gives she turns into a cat
it's like that let's take that scene and
make a movie for ours
okay I mean I could talk about this
because there's so many other topics
youtuber apologies what about them
there's a wait a break hey guys I just
want to say I'm really sorry this video
is sponsored by are you struggling with
depression but skip ad' this video is
brought to you by Colgate Colgate are
your teeth as sturdy and everything's
about growth and finding yourself and I
just couldn't take some time off and I
won't be posting on Twitter but I shot
some videos before and I'm gonna post
them also with no singles coming out
it's really [ __ ] cool they do have
merch but like I don't even know anymore
isn't feel comfortable for me to be
tweeting or anything about it but I am
wearing my new one so let me shoot this
video like
seven times you link in the bio oh my
god [ __ ] should we do it again did those
tears look real loser off getting your
quiz it out of focus okay I'll do it
again I feel like I wasn't being genuine
let's go outside so that I can get some
Sun in my eyes so real Oakes I'm crying
no leave the dog in the background
humanizes me perfect okay umm next you
just made it so that like 15 people
won't be your guests anymore overcoat
graze for 10 percent of okay people that
don't use their turn signals I think
we've talked about this in the past
actually it's [ __ ] furious your car
can only do so many things to
communicate and turn signals is one of
them why would you not use it here's
here's okay can I've come up with this
theory yeah
think of your car as a giant driving
helmet okay okay about it as your eyes
your ears it's a big dome mm-hmm metal
head that you're just driving around
what you want to look around or let
people know when you're about to do
something blink just blink that's all
you gotta [ __ ] do is blink right it's
like going up to someone when you have
to use a bathroom and you need to ask
where the bathroom is but you don't use
your words to ask someone you just start
peeing on their leg what do you doing
dude they're gonna be mad you made a
mistake and the cops are gonna be called
yeah
god it's I hate when people don't use
their turn signals when people just
slowly start to drift into your lane
you're like I guess you're in my lane
now yeah you know what's weird is I I
don't know why but every time something
like that happens I have to scream at
the top of my lungs as if they're gonna
hear me verbatim yeah where I'm always
like oh no it's always the same type of
car too sometimes I'm in an uber and
they're like who are you screaming at
and I'm like the red Buick you should be
mad too sir fandoms what about them
they're great I mean I love fandoms I
could be scary some that's what I mean I
don't like scary fandoms that are just
um
very live and die by the the adoration
for their person that they love yeah I
guess that is true face some fandoms are
I guess you know like you send a fandom
on a joke whim sometimes and all the
sudden it's just chaos it's out of
control but you know what that's just
one of the the peaks and valleys of the
Internet that's just when we mean look
comment sections were bound to do
something and I like silly fandoms I'd
what give me an example please I don't
even know if they exist gets the joke
that doesn't try to attack people for
like what they perceive as a attacks
against the person that they support I
think that might be jacksFilms yeah I
feel like jacksFilms has a great fandom
that understands like sarcasm I like
that his fandom is also very
understanding of other van't fandoms
that don't understand like the Y versus
I asked you yesterday where it's like he
made that up
I will sit here and say this as someone
who has nothing to do with it he did
PewDiePie did not make that up
yeah but it's so funny because people
are commenting on Jack's video thing
like you [ __ ] copy and PewDiePie you
[ __ ] loser and it's like his fans
like his commenters are like dude look
at the receipts he's been doing this for
years okay fandoms interesting fandoms
my favorite one right now is the area 51
people oh yes yes yes I just turned into
a music festival I heard really yeah the
person the person who was like in charge
of it was like yeah [ __ ] it it's a music
festival now dead serious he just went
on Facebook and changed it and so did he
watched any of the fire fest ducks and
that you can't just say this is a music
festival and then everything falls into
place but it's slowly becoming a fire
festival now and I'm just excited to see
what happened to watch what happens are
you gonna go no time now you're gonna be
in Ohio
you're right I might go back and then
fly for I might fly and just be the
front runner just the guy here in the
front is go get in line right now yes
live from LA to treat it like it's a
Black Friday situation I'm just sitting
there with a camper like just waiting
for that [ __ ] music faster come on get
me a big-screen TV
music festival will give me a big street
game and an alien yeah I'm very excited
for it
now that you've I didn't know it was
becoming a music festival now I'm very
excited I can't wait to see what it
comes up next I mean Alien Ant Farm has
to play right they don't answer the call
I don't know what they're doing with
their lives I mean what are they doing
with their what what's alien and farm up
to I know you're listening alien and
farm that's a comical gesture
oh my god that's all I know of them - oh
man no alien ant farm
you got to get with it um okay what
should and should not go on Pizza oh
okay I am a hard believer of no
pineapples on please
yeah me too so against it and it's weird
because people have been trying to
convert me especially in LA there's not
a fandom that arrests they're just like
yes but it's just a little bit it's the
opposite it's mommy I'm like no it's a
fruit that you've cooked and now it's on
a delicious cheesy thing I don't want
that yeah would you put a blueberry on
pizza
no that's also a fruit someone's crazy
you know that so I'm telling all these
pineapple on pizza lovers I understand
that you might that I don't like
pineapple really it ish ish it's not my
let go - it just doesn't seem it it
seems like the the most random fruit to
grab and throw on a pizza yeah it seems
like the fruit that's trying the hardest
to not get eaten so why would I combat
that oh my god oh my it's wearing like
its own chainmail you just blew my mind
it's so right like a bananas like here
peel away I got goodness inside you
don't even have to wash me yeah a bit of
pineapple is like good luck just make a
[ __ ] ice sculpture out of me and I
don't get ya then maybe throw me on a
hot steaming pizza throw cheese on me
you know I really I really think that it
was just about the fundamentals of this
cheese yeah tomato sauce and pineapple
yes and in most of time it's like ham -
and ham
they're always it's Hawaiian side and
I'm just like no that's that no and I'm
pretty liberal about like what can go on
Pizza me too
I mean I'm just yesterday I had a pizza
that was stuffed crust with a sweet
potato and it was delicious
it was delicious it sounds great that's
sweet and the savory I can get on board
wipe that face off your face it looks -
it was delicious but if it had showed up
with a pineapple on it I would have
thrown it out the window like my phone's
what else should not go on Pizza candy
chocolate do what chocolate be good on
pizza okay I'm over this whole concept
of people making sweet pizzas where it's
just like chocolates but did you just
invent something sweet says sweets us
death has to exist Grace's sweets's
she's opening up a sweet pizza shop but
like would it's like you you do like
chocolate and cheese fondue and things
like that buy like pair together not on
a pizza
now with the tomatoes yeah the tomato
sauce is what throws it off but the
tomato sauce is what throws everything
off okay okay cuz cheese and
this is fury aiding me okay this is fury
anything you it's making yeah it's it's
out fury is infuriated right and I'm
fury ated I am I'm exposed in my fury no
I I will say I think yes sweets don't
belong on pizza I don't think any sort
of candies belong on pizza I also don't
believe in the whole pizza thing where
there's no [ __ ] cheese and you know
what I'm talking about Mel cigarette
where it's just like heavy sauce and
then like meat and they're like that's
it
and then they do they'll turn it up too
which is like no sauce and it's just
cheese which is just garlic bread yes
yes essentially it's so dry look if it's
doesn't have sauce and cheese and bread
it's not pizza
it's just like an open-faced sandwich
thing what do you think about eggs on
pizza book that I hate it Wow I hate
eggs so much fried egg look I get it
it's probably delicious sure to some
people but to me I don't want a little
baby far chilling in the middle of my
pizza because that's what it smells like
a little chicken fart the moment
somebody starts eating that you like
move what's that smell yikes and that's
gonna smell worse later ooh God grazie
it's a preview to the feature-length
film oops it's gonna smell worse later
it's gonna get worse I mean can you
imagine what the James Corden whole
scene is gonna be we got to move on I'm
sorry James Corden see I don't know but
he says something right in someone's
face and I was like that's weird that he
would even be okay to do that Wow and I
also just think of Mike Myers in the Cat
in the Hat all the time and I'm like if
he doesn't show up at least for a second
I just go wow wow a missed opportunity
for a great cameo mm-hmm okay last one
before we take a quick break for sure or
maybe maybe not the whole number
neighbor scheme do what number name
where people were like texting their Jew
tax I did not I did not know I was too
afraid Sam I saw I saw too many things
on Instagram of people being very very
mean to be getting threatened by their
neighbor and then I was like you know
what's the least thing I want a person
who hates me to have my phone
it's my most vulnerable thing I was
expecting someone to text me that day
you know I I thought about this the
other day I was like should I feel sad
that I never got the text yeah from any
from either neighbor honestly I didn't
think sadness I just thought like I must
have like such a unique phone number I
genuine was like it's like kids at a
table not wanting to sit next to you
yeah I must be so intimidating the cool
can I get like a thousand away from
Mitchell I don't want to be his number
neighbor I don't actually call him but I
also feel like because you know how the
the geriatric app that everyone was
using the old person app to make them
their face old butt face app base app is
that what it was called yeah you that
creative name because that face app I
you know how everyone said that like
Russians were getting everyone's data
and information after it yes yeah so I
don't trust this number neighbor scheme
to not be some sort of marketing ploy or
some sort of like data pulling ploy I
don't know how yet I haven't gotten to
the theory I haven't gotten past just
the initial theory because there isn't
there's got to be some there's some
seedy underbelly did this like seemingly
fun harmless prank that the Internet has
made viral you live your life as if it's
stranger stranger things from stranger
things I'm at a 10 in my paranoia
constantly and I never come down that
explains all the Christmas lights yeah
he's like if I go days without posting
on social media now you guys know why
I'm just yelling at my walls knocking on
I'm trying to find out who's in there
that's it was definitely just so much
twelve-year-olds dumb idea where yes oh
but can you imagine hearing about like
yeah in 2019 we're gonna do this thing
called number neighbor like that sounds
scary and creepy and like I don't want
to be part of that what do you thinks
gonna be the next one
the number
initiative uh cuz this is so I'm there
is like oh like alternatively I'm
surprised that we haven't done this
earlier this is such a simple concept
well I mean I feel like we're finally
living in the age where nobody gives a
[ __ ] about like like minutes or anything
like we finally are living in that age
where it's like a phone thing nobody
that doesn't happen you just always get
the new phone every time and it doesn't
[ __ ] matter whereas before it was
like yo bro I got 18 minutes we need to
talk for five of those and I'm gonna
send five texts out of my 15 for the
month that was it you had yeah you had
like a cache a you had a limit maybe it
was happening we just even know it I
don't know but we should come up with
the next viral sensation prank situation
it's a lot of pressure grace yeah it is
imma let someone else do it okay I'm
done perfect
okay well well let's take a quick break
and when we get back we have a bunch
more but I want to kind of vet these a
little bit so we're not just like
talking about the same [ __ ] over and
over again so guys go text your number
neighbor during this break and let us
know how it goes or come up with the new
viral texting harmless prank and let us
know Sarah by us replies and we'll take
credit for it at once
participate it's ours we're gonna steal
it from you yeah this is a binding
verbal contract than anything you
tweeted at us is ours in its entirety
we own the entire property and all of
the movies that will be made here into
forth to the future legalese legalese
we'll be right back up we're not too
deep
[Music]
to deep support for today's show comes
from third love with more than 70 sizes
including their signature half cup sizes
third love designs bras with breast size
and shape in mind for a perfect fit and
premium feel you guys have heard me talk
about third love in the past and I still
stay connected with the thought that
they're fantastic they've sent me their
products and there's some one that wears
basically like ace bandages for bras
these are comfortable fashionable they
make me feel classy and supported all at
the same time they're hands-down the
most comfortable bra that you'll own
they have straps that don't slip they've
tag list labels and not to mention
lightweight super thin memory foam cups
that mold to your shape and are
proprietary to third love best of all
every customer has 60 days to wear it
wash it and put it to the test if you
don't love it you can return it and
third level wash it and donate it to a
woman in need third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering you beautiful listeners
15% of your first order go 2/3 love.com
slash grace now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love calm slash grace for
15% off today you guys know we love
Squarespace and guess what they love us
because they're supporting this episode
of not too deep and they want to turn
your dream into a reality they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project do you want to start a new
business do you want to showcase that
work do you want to publish your content
do you want to sell products do you want
to do more
well Squarespace is the tool for you
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself they
also have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time plus
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
you'll get all the help you need with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people we're talking designers
lawyers artists artists artists gamers
restaurants and gyms to turn great ideas
into something real so go to Squarespace
com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com
such grace offer code grace okay um
who Heather M is heated here we go okay
just because your family had to leave
the hotel at 5:00 a.m. to catch a flight
doesn't mean that all of us are awake
stop having lengthy loud conversations
down the hotel corridors while I'm
sleeping Wow
Heather hey I feel like something
specific happened Heather I feel like
for some reason she was at a swim meet I
don't know why I am usually pretty okay
with like noise in hotel rooms just from
living in New York but recently I was in
Portland and the night of the after
memory and I did a show I was going to
sleep and these [ __ ] upstairs we're
just like walking around it was like
they were doing the chicken dance for
six hours straight I just heard
footsteps constantly in this like what I
assume is a small space up there like
every single footstep I heard to the
point that I turned into like a
crotchety old woman in like a kids movie
and I just started kid like punching the
ceiling didn't get them in here like
that it was like 3:00 a.m. they're
probably like the bottom floor loves it
too yes that's our base dude that's our
they stood on the bed it was like
jumping up to the ceiling and punching
it yeah you old mean lady
I got crotchety you got to get you get
your and start traveling with a broom
just so you can see look for anything
handle like you find something with a
handle yeah I couldn't I will say this
about that and I think about this quite
a bit is I'm really [ __ ] sick of
hotel rooms that are like facing the
corridor of the hotel and not outside
yes that shit's not okay yeah I'm really
it's almost dare I say a prank that the
hotel pulls on you and they're like look
at the view and then you open the
windows and you're like people checking
in great yeah I can't do anything and it
is very [ __ ] loud the whole time I've
ever told your memories story about that
we were in a hotel and like are that are
somewhere on tour years ago and she had
a room that
the interior of the hotel didn't really
realize it and she had like we had a
couple hours before we had to go to our
show we both went to our rooms and we're
just chilling out and then she texted me
she's like oh my god we've been doing
room strike a half hour I was like what
happened I'll tell you when you come
over to her hers I went over to her room
to rehearse and all the windows curtains
are drawn and she's like I got into the
room and I have it's on by myself I get
into my birthday suit just completely
everything's out there and I'm like
flipping through the channels watching
reality TV and it's just like I got a
knock on the door and I put a robe on
and I answer it and it's this woman like
a middle-aged woman and she goes ma'am
my family and I are staying in a room
across the way and my children have just
seen you completely naked and she look
cause she didn't realize that the window
that she had went to the inside she it
looks like an illusion it looked like it
was looking outside so these kids she
looked over and it's just like a family
in a window oh my god I was just sitting
here watching HGTV butt-ass naked kids
saw it so guys that's a tale that should
warn you it's a cautionary tale I'm
saying it's a prank if you messed up oh
my god she literally those kids are like
this is the sexiest ooh I've ever been
knocked on her door and told her that
she should shut her or the opposite that
the mom was like what are you kids
looking hey I'm gonna be right back you
two did I mention both these kids are 21
and 25 yeah so beware yeah no seriously
be careful sorry it was just it was
traumatic for me to like it is just not
an okay situation I mean speaking of
parents someone when someone says
parents who show you 1,000 pictures of
their kids look why I don't approve that
they're not a psychopath that's
pretending and making up a child I mean
you just got show me one and even even
then you could pull it off the internet
and if it looked enough like yeah
becsher yeah exactly and listen even if
you have the absolute cutest child in
the history of children I don't need to
see them in various places doing various
things I mean the only time that I think
it's appropriate for you to be like hey
check us out is if you find out that
your kid has a superpower yes then I'm
like we're pretty interested you know
I'm saying camera girl like I mean if
its unless it's doing something amazing
where it has a tail whoa okay that was a
like that but yeah I mean unless it
there's something incredible
yeah about this baby that enriches my
life because you're showing me this in
what I imagine is the hopes that this is
gonna make my day better when you should
know that this makes it worse it's just
yeah I doesn't you know it doesn't make
me feel old it doesn't it just makes me
feel like less of an adult it makes me
feel like I'm wasting my time
oh wow that's it's like I yes see I'm
sure these children mean a lot to you
but you are now asking me to provide you
with some sort of like validation yeah
support on the baby job yes yeah you did
it sex is fun isn't it don't you don't
you [ __ ] you did it a little different
no okay glad that you didn't wear
protection
yes that's gonna be with you forever
yeah I am but see I do understand the
showing of pets and maybe that's because
I have a pet well that's the same thing
I know it's the same thing I just like
dogs again I'm only excited if they're
like I just got my dog cut in this crazy
thing or like something it's a video
there or doing something yeah doing a
trick or mimicking a human sound cuz for
some reason I'm so [ __ ] into that
when animals are like hey I'm like
that's what I say you can't say that or
like when a dog's like almost like [ __ ]
that that's amazing that freaks me out
I'll watch those videos for days but if
it's just a video of a dog being a dog
I'm like who gives a [ __ ] yeah who gives
I'll go to a dog park by myself until
they kick me out
I'll get one
DHD for kak right in front of me watch
this
yeah watch this watch me throw a tennis
ball fifteen dog show up they don't even
mind and then you take their phone and
you throw it out your window when I text
they're freaking number neighbor it's my
number that's what you should do when
someone starts showing you photos of
their kids or dogs just say oh can I see
that and take their phone and then text
a random or actually just text that
picture to that random number so they'd
be like hey that's another person you
could talk to about these pictures
comments I'll get [ __ ] another name but
it three dots there you go yeah go into
their contacts quickly search the word
letters e^x they're gonna get a text
back for sure your kids are real cute
okay someone says the woes of
drive-throughs whoo [ __ ] em they make me
so anxious theory great convenient you
don't really have to deal with people I
was gonna say yeah on paper it makes so
much sense it is genius and then you get
to in and out and you're like this is
the math hell this is hell
pure panic and then you're stuck yeah
you can't go forward or backwards it's
look as a kid before I took any sort of
medications before I took any sort of
anything I remember there'd be times
where my family was like let's all go to
blankety-blank and I'd be like that's
like 30 minutes of me being trapped and
a big man cage would know anything yeah
and I know might eat in here and that
was always the scariest part is like
that initial fast food in your gut while
you're still in a belly of car people I
don't know yeah just made me feel really
scared and I was not know I hated it but
now as an adult again still great in
theory but then you get there and the
pressures of I don't know why every
single place doesn't offer you the menu
first before you get to the box where
you have to place your order and you
have to look at this menu and then it
because
just a magic I to me like the menu I
just looked directly at it soft focus
and I'm not looking at anything and I'm
just feeling I'm like counting seconds
in my head of how silent I've how long
I've been silent to the person that's
asking me for my order and it's just a
torture chamber for me and then I order
something that I don't want because a
car behind me it looks like they're
ravenous yeah okay that's the thing that
I have always think about I'm constantly
thinking about the people in front of me
and behind me and I'm just like they
must be starving starving good of people
and I have to continue moving also this
is the thing that really throws me off
is I hate when it starts off with a
voice and then it ends with a totally
another voice and I'm like wait any of
my order get told to the right person
well it's just like hey welcome to
Wendy's and then you give your order and
it's like great 3560 switch just happen
that's like that's happened to me so
many times that it's thrown me off or
I've been like can I just give you my
order again new guy and they're like no
no I'm just we have a window and I'm
like yeah but I'm just I don't feel
comfortable like I'm making it about me
now but I mean I'm giving you my
business I just want to make sure that
we're all on the same page yeah I mean
like I don't I want to know where my
tips go you know I got I'm gonna get the
order of the thing that I hastily
ordered that I don't actually want
because I'm too nervous about who's in
front I mean who's behind me right now
you know I will say when you double it
down yeah like places like Subway mm-hmm
that makes me almost feel like I'm gonna
pass out when they're just like what
cheese and I'm like oh god I don't even
know what all the cheeses are called let
alone which one I want they and they
they don't try to tell you like what
they all are they're just like what
cheese no they're not they're to like a
customer service and there's like I
don't only like six but in the moment
there's a hundred and ten I know and I
always end up choosing provolone I don't
know why and it's like not it'll be not
an on provolone sandwich and they're
like are you sure I'm like yes you ready
I said it I always go like this I always
go uh the white one and there's always
like three white ones and they're like
sir do you mean the blank the blank or
the blank and I'm like who
yes yeah and I always end up just paying
for two cheese's I mean that maybe is a
genius plan
we went recently Elliot and I went to
subway the other day and we were a
little high and it was a great choice
only when you eat subway yeah and we
went in and it was empty and this one
guy was helping us and I was like I want
all the vegetables he's like all of them
was like mm-hmm
and then he starts making it and we're
both a little stoned so we're not
talking at all and at one point he looks
up and he goes oh you guys are making me
nervous
Oh what oh my god he goes you weren't
talking I thought you were just like
watching me work whereas we're just like
looking around separately the rest of
the subway we're like no man no sorry
sorry no we're just like very tired he's
like okay okay in his perspective he is
right we were two [ __ ] weirdos I said
I want all the vegetables and then it
was just pure silence yeah that's that's
definitely like your fault
we're sure our fault it's like that's
like going to one of those yogurt shops
and being like yeah can I just get a bag
of just the bubbles and then just
walking away just being like wait you
want me just to keep scooping the butt
okay what sighs it makes me boy happy to
know that there is nervous as we are
yeah yeah I felt so and he was so nice
and he was so good he made honestly
maybe the best sandwich I've ever had I
mean you were sewing of course it was
the best thing yeah it wouldn't even
close it was great yeah I'm like if any
it probably was just a shoe with a bunch
of vegetables every lace okay mixing
foods on plates or or against Oh against
separate that stuff I mean they're even
it but even if it's like Thanksgiving no
no I'm not that guy I don't like my food
touching it's that there's look I've
take a lot of medicine and there's some
things nothing will fix just can't I
can't do that healthy boundaries
boundaries with my health but it is yeah
it is a real [ __ ] thing like I
remember the first two Thanksgivings I
went to I actually was like can someone
just make lasagna for me and my boy was
like I get like the smallest stripe is
not like a lasagna because I was just
like cuz then it's just one big thing
that can touch itself deconstructed
lasagna no this is not [ __ ] chefs hey
hey it was my grandmother she just
wanted to do you want me to put here and
then there's no sauce it's just a smoke
she puts in my face
that's the saw eating delicious
Thanksgiving food and you're just saying
that's what it was yes in coleslaw
because I was like that's the one thing
I do like that was my life of my early
teens it was amazing and it's like still
a thing now we've moved at E like
because Easter I'm always like Easter
but anyways my whole family gets
together and still has like a proper
dinner and I'm always like this that's
my lasagna day now I'm always like
where's the lasagna for my gods
[Laughter]
okay weirdly over-the-top Bloody Marys I
think are great I love a Bloody Mary I
love them I love the the garish ones
that are so overly accessorized I in
theory and Instagram photos look great
in reality when you get one of those
it's like ordering fajitas at a
restaurant and it's a you are so
attention-seeking that you want the rest
of the restaurant to watch you and your
thing that's food and a show at the same
time yeah and then getting it into your
body is the most awkward thing in the
world so you cross the stick
yeah it's on a stick and it's like
shrimp and cheese and bacon and olives
and like a cheeseburger that's too
small and it's all kind of got a little
bit of tomato juice on it so handling it
with your hands just getting red juice
everywhere and it's like you are an
[ __ ]
I have always put those in the same
realm of like that person who's like can
I get the Tiki drink that's on fire and
huge like you're doing something you're
going for something here at this bar and
there's no way that you cannot say like
oh this is a little much it's like well
what do you expect yeah you're turning
this bar into a tiny personal Benihana
for yourself there's a reason he was
away for 20 minutes making it cuz he had
a fry up paddy I know I've seen photos
of the bloody marys that have like half
a burger I'm like no this is now you
guys are getting dumb this is too silly
when the balancing system eventually I
just I can't its Jenga it's gonna topple
over it just doesn't make 7u a Bloody
Mary with a plate on the side like take
the Bloody Mary out of it okay just
think if you ordered a meal and was like
mm could you balance all that on my
drink yeah all as kabob style yeah can I
get a burger medium-rare and on a stick
and could it be floating on top of the
drink just it's a little moist but it's
still edible cuz I'll be drunk
I want wet buns yeah it's just a strange
situation look I get it it's like a
weird thing but I'm gonna be real with
you if you ordered one and that's you
were like I didn't expect this then what
were you expecting yeah because even a
Bloody Mary with a piece of celery like
a celery stalk in it is so awkward to
eat that thing rattles around and slaps
you in the nose every time you try and
take a sip I remember I remember when
you had those on this show and like the
early seasons and there was an episode
with Elliot actually where I was editing
it and I had to cut so many things cuz
he kept trying to take drinks and poking
his own with the [ __ ] celery thing
because no one ever took the celery out
I think because they were being like a
gracious guest but I wanted to be like
it's for show you could you don't have
to keep it and so many people just kept
the sellers like idiots you just stir
that [ __ ] and then take a bite and set
it on the table and he's just like
trouble
years like being the host saying the
ordinary and he's like poking his own
[ __ ] I'll come so funny good feeling
good feeling very cathartic yeah I just
peed my pants okay here's a solid rant
topic it's a photo of all the new Heinz
Mayo concoctions have you seen this what
Heinz ketchup has created Mayo must
crash Mayo chip when Mayo cute and I
guess what these are mixtures of okay
what's the first one Mayo must Mayo must
that's mayonnaise and a musty old man
yep okay Krantz Krantz
that's Krampus and ranch but he stepped
in at first yeah exactly
yes mayo Chuck Mayo Chuck that's Mayo
that someone upchucked already and then
they put it in a bottle and added a
horseradish yes
mayo cue Mayo cue that that's actually a
new hospital that they're building
yes ma okey yes I feel like we just did
$64,000 pyramid is mustard and
mayonnaise ooh
cran CH I is it I think it's ketchup
ranch okay and then Mayo Chuck I don't
know what this is mayonnaise ketchup
yes mayonnaise ketchup he sound like
this like the movie Step Brothers like
those two characters are like hi we have
four ideas for new flavors dipping
sauces
we call these specials yeah and then
Mayo Q which is mayonnaise BBQ combine
here you can see the photo oh my god
these are real as far as I understand I
don't know what I feel about these
because I do like both mayonnaise and
ketchup on my french fries I do like man
I do like ketchup and mustard on my
french fries together and I'll mix that
together but this feels excessive this
feels a lot like that whole concept or
they were like peanut butter and jelly
in one jar yeah remember those yeah
there's like striped yeah I feel like a
lot of people have a lot of hatred
towards mayonnaise and they're trying to
cute enough mayonnaise for people that
hate it you think so many says we're
trying to make it more accessible
I mean mayonnaise is just it's a admit
but Mayo q what would you put mayonnaise
on that you would also put barbeque on
a chicken sandwich maybe I don't know I
guess a sandwich yeah but I'm trying to
think of like baby back ribs you're
throwing slapping some mayonnaise on
some baby back ribs yeah this feels like
we're getting dangerously close to like
food team where they're like just say
it's food but you have to say trademark
I'm like why and they're like just you
have to yeah I don't these I think
bother me because it's like go-gurt
yeah yoke I hate go-gurt like to an
extreme that doesn't make sense you know
what's crazy is I feel like these would
have done a lot better if they had just
been like they're completely new things
we've made them up they're just new
sauces why why mayo must I know the
names the name is stupid the names are
like they these idiots won't [ __ ]
know what's in here so we got to give
them context clues what's in here these
are all named like apps I would download
and delete in a minute where it's like I
download it because I needed you use it
because the only app to let me cross
yeah this is like someone that can't
remember their password so they keep
typing in all these other variation I
don't know crash crash deleted Pokemon
Krantz sounds like something I would say
when I'm too high where I'm like dude
faster crash crash me up bar oh dude it
sounds like a strain of wheat it's out
yeah yeah we just got some purple has
some crunch some data crunch and we got
Mayo must which is really [ __ ] good
so got like a must it's a month
it's got like a must ear it's a og and
it's a mixture between your cookies and
mayonnaise huh yeah we just let that
[ __ ] grow Manas yeah I think maybe like
fully legalized weed in the Heinz
Factory oh yeah for sure
that's what all the speckles are in the
crash you can actually legally smoke
that oh my god okay we're gonna take one
last break and then we're gonna get to
some more rant topics via
oh good I'm getting a call from fraud
risk I gotta take this call guys we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
- deep if there's something interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals better help
online counseling can help they offer
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts lgbtq+ matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment and get help
at your own time and at your own pace
anything you share is confidential it's
convenient you can schedule video or
phone sessions as well as chat and text
with your therapist and if for some
reason you're not happy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
anytime for no additional charge and
it's affordable and you will get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace by going to better help calm slash
grace then simply fill out a
questionnaire to help them assess your
needs and get matched with the counselor
that you'll love that's better help con
slash grace today we have support from
Warby Parker prescription eyewear
shouldn't cost more than a plane ticket
with Warby Parker you can get high
quality good looking prescription
eyewear at a fraction of the price every
pair is custom fit with anti reflective
polycarbonate prescription lenses
available exclusively through Warby
Parker's website and retail stores
you simply take their quiz answer a few
questions and they'll suggest
great-looking glasses that are totally
personalized to your face and style with
Warby Parker's free home a trial program
you can order five pairs of glasses and
try them for five days there's no
obligation to buy
they even ship free and include a
prepaid return shipping label head to
Warby Parker dot-com slash Grace to
order your free home try on glasses
start at $95 including prescription
lenses and include anti glare and anti
scratch coatings blue light filtering
lenses are also now available and if you
have an iPhone X you can download Warby
Parker's app and use their brand new
virtual Tryon to see the realistic color
texture and size of each style using
just your phone
my mom is obsessed with Warby Parker
glasses she wears the crap out of them
she looks beautiful in them she's done
the whole at-home process I've gotten
all the photos of all of her options
I've helped her choose this is a brand
that I couldn't support more so why not
try it out take the quiz and find a pair
that's perfect for you today head to
Warby Parker comm / grace let's get into
some last little rant topics here okay
okay
are they be specifically little you tell
me okay goldfish tastes too much like
cheez-its I've never thought about this
before they are this the same thing
they're the same thing right just in
different flavor form see I swindled
this whole time out flavor form in shape
for shape I don't know I'm not gonna lie
though I always go for a cheese it do
you yeah wow you just looked at me like
I'm a [ __ ] serial killer Oh cuz I was
trying to think of what I go to you I've
been on lots of flights where cheez-its
have been the only viable like snacks or
so I've been eating a lot more cheese
that's recently but if I had the choice
I might go goldfish goldfish to me
seemed like something that a child's
already put their hand in touched all
over did taking their hand out even if
it's a fresh batch I'm like isn't that
part of like the flavor though the
flavor profiles of five-year-olds
fingers it's just yeah finger grime
that's where you get the salt it's for
your [ __ ] skin man but I never
realized that they're the same yeah
damn dude [ __ ] that's a collab that's
were waiting for whoa yeah basically god
damn okay sorry that blew my mind okay
let's see unpacking what about it
just like information or packing clothes
we're talking about unpacking ranting
like I hate unpacking
I mean unpacking this tie hang I don't
do it I never do it I've never unpacked
I'm not gonna lie to you really when I
go places I leave everything packed up
in my bag and I legit take things out
and then repack them before I leave my
hotel room yeah I I don't use the hotel
things I don't use any of it no I leave
everything in my bag I don't I don't use
a hotel like wardrobe never no Hannah
does that it freaks me out I'm like how
long are you staying
yeah is very strange to me whenever I am
in a hotel and I go to someone's room
for a drink or something packed and they
have like all their [ __ ] in the bathroom
like a normal bathroom I'm like it would
somebody okay I took me like four or
five trips to VidCon for I realized that
was a thing that not everybody does
where that they don't all keep it in
like me but they just like keep it
packed up this could be really symbolic
of your like emotional trauma for sure
like the day that I actually unpack my
bags I sob and I sit on the bed and I
realize who I am as a person this
question is about emotional unpacking
whoa let's move on quickly my next
question without any further
introspection of that pants with pockets
sewn shut
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] oh yeah you
know what makes those the devil yeah
they're terrible stupid also if you're
gonna make if you're gonna if I'm gonna
mm-hmm if I'm gonna pay so much money
for a suit and those suit pockets you're
not you're gonna go yeah they're made
there but we don't ever rip them out
because that's how suits are I'm like
guess what is that suits work yes one of
the [ __ ] things about suits is it's
like we make pockets for them but it's
it's Nonie you don't ever button the
bottom and top and the leaves these
pockets stay so I'm like my [ __ ] open
it all up let me put my [ __ ] in my
pocket I'm going to a wedding and I'm
gonna wanna take snacks home and I'm
gonna also want to sit down and I have
this giant [ __ ] phone I just don't
want to be that guy open this one up
sometimes man it's great it is crazy
I've never thought about that before
yeah men soon
our seemingly simple but these are all
connect they're just touched up yeah and
the etiquette of like the button
situation is stupid yeah and like when
you got to go to the bathroom you're
basically taking off an entire suit it's
so it's insane cuz then you're like I
don't want to get any bathroom water on
in it but it's all sitting on the ground
and the tail of the suit like why the
[ __ ] does it even have a tail yeah I
think about [ __ ] pockets
there was a rant about women's pockets
which is [ __ ] that women have
pockets that are basically besides
Lessing yeah use lists
I guess because we're supposed to have
purses or bags or that situation so if
that's so [ __ ] silly though everybody
hands I got big et fingers that can't go
in teeny tiny little lady pockets and I
have so much [ __ ] I need a bag yeah
stupid also I get socially anxious where
is this to put my hands that's another
thing is like what what do I do when I'm
like no I'm approachable hi I can't just
cross my arms in front of my chests to
keep my hands you know busy if that
makes me look like I'm closed off yeah
you ever answered questions on a red
carpet with your arms crossed no you
don't do that but I'm gonna start doing
it I'm gonna start trying to look like a
pouty little girl every time I go on a
red carpet
okay I want someone to design a suit
that has a hoodie pocket or like a
button-down shirt that has like hidden
pockets inside two connected pockets oh
my god like a little hand warmer that's
what I mean like those old like those
cuff things yes it's their thick
seamless lease like okay I feel like
this is Kanye's new jumpsuits have it
right cuz they have pockets and then
they have slits in the side so that you
can reach in your real pockets that's
what I'm talking about it's like when
you wear like a jumpsuit there's it
we're like that's a bad bathroom
situation it's a terrible bathroom
situation but if we're talking pockets
it's a great pocket so could you get
double the pocket äj-- that's true so I
mean cuz right then you gotta get like
fully nude when you go to the bathroom a
pair of shorts underneath
then when you get more news for your
shorts I was gonna say and then when you
go to the bathroom and you get fully
nude you just hang it up on the thing
and you just really enjoy yourself you
take about 15 for yourself you know I
mean okay maybe splash a little water
sir I've never done this I've never done
this this is crazy I will say sometimes
when someone leaves with the suit to go
or when they're in a jumpsuit and they
they're like let me go the bathroom real
quick I'm always like 20 minutes man 20
months oh it's the worst guys I love
jumpsuits I love it I love the ease of
just like a one-piece situation but the
bathroom situation is always a condom
[ __ ] I have actually like
accidentally dropped like the sleeves of
a jumpsuit into the toilet and then
you're in the bathroom just full panic
and you don't know what to do and it's
just terrible is for me it's always like
I will I will have like a jacket on that
like it's tied around my waist I pull it
down and it just gets into that watery
floor oh you don't even know why it's
that cold why is it that cold in there I
don't know and how long has this water
been sitting here what kind of bacteria
has grown in here yeah I was actually
recently in line to use the bathroom and
the guy in front of me was like look bro
it's gonna look like I'm going in and
coming out but I'm actually gonna go in
make a water toilet paper and just clean
up and then come back out and throw it
away don't skip me and I was like okay
oh he went in the storm was like I'm
cleaning everything up and then I'm
gonna come back out with like two wads
of whatever and throw away a good
Samaritan
yeah but a lot of people were mad that
made that for letting him do that little
hole dance took a while and then when he
went in there he just started playing
music and I was like okay now you've
gotten music in his in this in just the
one singular stall that this play this
restaurant had I was like Joyce I mean I
get if you're playing music to divert
from taking like a massive [ __ ] but if
anything you're drawing more attention
to yourself and your stuff oh I mean he
was yeah he was in it he was in it he
was he was like if I'm gonna go I'm
gonna relax III imagine that this dude
took his shirt off and was like
water what I'm doing I really felt like
you mean he was in there for a while Wow
I mean he sounds like he has he has a
system yeah definitely okay someone said
men spitting on the ground in public I
mean just spitting in public is [ __ ]
strange I think fitting in general is uh
I mean when you're just doing it to
what's what's what's pity I don't I'm
trying to remember the last time I saw
someone like spit in public and I think
it wasn't insane lot yeah cowboy
I don't yeah it's gross I mean I've seen
it a few times but it's always like an
older man doing it then I guess assumes
that this is fine you know what I
changed my mind I don't give a [ __ ] spit
it's better all you want I'll give [ __ ]
like if you're in line to board a plane
and someone just spits if you're outside
spit if you're inside don't spit he has
spoken I am the spirit Lord
okay people in summer people in summer I
don't know what that means exactly oh
how much bluetooths suck no you know
it's weird bluetooth has like aged so
well and bad at the same time it's
incredible
yeah we don't know what to do with it
we're just like I guess this year it'll
be for transferring photos quickly and
next year it'll be for connecting
headphones that don't have any cord yeah
we've never touched the logo we touch
the logos on all kinds of stuff all the
I think about the Bluetooth all the time
I have the boots like it at the booth
all go tattooed on me but also that's
what we used to just call the like
someone had a bluetooth or they had like
the headpiece that they would take phone
calls on yeah and now it's a broader
description of things yeah that's what
I'm saying it's grown into this weird
like it's like people saying kid you
have a tissue you know what I mean
they're clean yeah yeah it's like that
now it's this thing that's like archaic
I imagine that if we go back far enough
there's Bluetooth fetch tin walls that
symbol of caveman being like we use this
for that to connect with son back in
like the Egyptian pyramid yeah yeah like
that was actually the bit like blue that
symbol came from an alien
in the Egyptian time yes always I hate
when you try and like connect your
Bluetooth to a car and it's like cannot
find I'm I guess you can can
[ __ ] I'm right here both of you
hey don't talk to each other I know that
you were upset with each other last time
but please yeah the sake of my scary
podcast I want to listen to that gives
me nightmares what is it wait what is it
what is it monster I'm listening to
season 2 about the Zodiac killer and I
shouldn't who you're scaring scaring
myself constantly little okay I'm just
gonna throw this at you the AH cumin
reader to recommend the untitled amazing
Jonathan documentary super good super
good check it out okay I gotta see it
okay pyramid schemes speaking of the
pyramid I mean a pyramid scheme is it's
exactly what you thought it's it's it's
a really good investment yeah and we
have some ideas for you that we would
love to get you guys interested in you
don't have to like it's not a consistent
signup you can buy one and be done yeah
so all you have to do is give us five
dollars and then you get one grace buck
yes one not to debug scuse me and then
that not too deep buck you can buy up
for three of those you get a live lava
live buck what you got yes and then it
just keeps and then if you bring three
friends on you'll get an extra not your
deep buck and we have a merch store
that's connected that takes both bucks
but you gotta convert those into
bitcoins yes and then that money it goes
back into the store and if your three
friends bring three friends and then you
get a bonus for each one of those
friends that they bring it and you have
to make sure that you're at least on
call 12 hours a day yes and we also have
tiny lipsticks if you want them ha bit
look whoever invented the pyramid scheme
maybe is a genius whoever gets involved
in pyramid schemes how the [ __ ] did you
do that multi-level marketing scheme
like anytime I see someone who's
describing a pyramid scheme and doesn't
realize it I'm always how are you doing
this yeah how are you saying it so I so
like I see it but you don't that's
amazing it really is but like it's just
it's it's a guy's just like it's like an
art form it's hard to listen to and
there's still so many that's what that's
what I'm saying like there's still it's
still a very
you'll thing and like I hear people
discuss like there was this video that
went viral like months ago that was like
someone on twitch just describing their
company and then everyone's like you're
describing a pyramid see he's like no
I'm not and he definitely was and I was
just like dude this is crazy
he made one and didn't even know it open
your eyes they could be everywhere even
in your mirror okay last one boob sweat
oh my god it's so [ __ ] real guys
girls everybody boy it's just it's a
thing yeah it happens it's you got you
got folds and flaps on your body and you
know they accumulate humidity yeah I
wouldn't even consider it just to the
boob now I would say just any layer of
flap fold or thing body sweat you got
hidden it's uh it's a thing for me it's
always just always just right in the ass
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Shammi like divers used to dry
themselves off when they get out of the
water genius could I get catch that on
flights so often even if I'm freezing
cold because I like cross my legs to
stay warm and then I stand up and I'm
like did I piss myself what just
happened it's like no I've created a
cavernous area of humidity in my body
yeah but if I had a chamois panty I'd be
safe I'm taking this defunct shark tank
and you cannot stop me none of you can
stop me
dear shark % initial startup for the
Shamy panty now I have any of you just
out of curiosity right now who here has
swamp ass yeah who here wishes there's a
ShamWow just shoved right up in there
yeah
right up with consent coming for colors
there all need you've stitched a sham
while - yeah it's like folded twice it's
just velcroed on top of underwear it's a
quick change tighty whities chamois this
is basically becoming a diaper oh yeah
but like a fashion diaper diaper not
extra movement for your sweat don't piss
on it it's not made for that let's be
very clear this is not for piss or [ __ ]
if you're gonna drive across country to
kill somebody don't wear these no get
depends you got to get the pens
yeah these you can also depend on wow I
feel cleansed that we really got a lot
off her chest and a lot of opinions that
you know got unearthed that I didn't
know that I had I feel good she's always
therapeutic I hope you guys enjoyed this
some classic clean-cut brands yeah back
to what we do best is she safest we do
business maybe like on like number 13
okay I was gonna say like our skills
there are other places this is what for
some reason people like Mitchell where
can people find you and everything
you're up to um my websites CD emoji
calm you can watch me on YouTube at live
lava live TV you also have some really
cool designs out right now yeah
represent calm such wavy - yeah really
awesome you guys should check them out
thank you
oh yeah yeah it's my clothing line it's
not merch it's not anything like that
it's just strictly I just wanted to make
fashion yeah they close they're great
highly highly recommend you know I've
got new ones coming out soon coming from
the girl in just a plain maroon fashion
from grace what recent style great taste
Mitchell thank you so much thank you
until next time until the next Rance
we'll see you guys on another episode of
not too deep goodbye too deep too deep
deep deep whatever struggles you're
facing depression anxiety trauma grief a
better help can connect you with a
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment it's
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and anything
you share is completely confidential and
best of all it's affordable and you'll
get 10% off your first month with a
discount code grace so get started by
going to better help calm such grace
fill out a questionnaire and get matched
with a counselor that you'll love today
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer Melissa
Dumont's writing by Diane Kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]